[Music]
hello happy Wednesday butan middle of
the week but we got some fun stuff you
informed me earlier this week to some
hype some cool stuff that we can
actually show early and Assassin's Creed
Odyssey yep I like do you think they did
the acronym ACO again on purpose oh I
didn't even think of that it's like it's
like when they did heroes of the storm
and heart of the swarm they had the hot
acronym anyways it was it was throwing
me off for a second anyways Charlie's
gonna kind of go through what we can
show which is mainly just like side
missions yeah what else can you show us
we then show pretty much everything from
the game that isn't story based okay so
I have a save about 15 hours in and as
you can see I have explored very little
of the map at a point in the save it's
great and there this game is big nice so
yeah we can just show off pretty much
anything in the game as long as we're
not showing story stuff which menus
there are some menus we can't show okay
so what's the first thing we're gonna do
here uh well I have a conquest battle
right here
sweet did you start off with this so for
those of you don't know maybe I'll come
back to the menu for a sec each region
is controlled by either Sparta or marked
athens and they're like having a war
right now and you can basically
manipulate the war you go in and and so
like here's sparta is controlling this
region and you can go in and you can
kill their leader you can like destroy
their warlike supplies and this little
menu here on the right hand side the
right-hand side where it says like
fortified I can like discover their
leader I can kill them and I can kind of
reduce them and once I reduce them
enough I can engage in what is called a
conquest battle nice right pick which
side I want to I want to side with you
can pick the invading army which gets
you more loot or you can pick with the
defending army which can see less loot
but it's a little easier it's also kind
of weird that you can basically destroy
like for example this is Sparta's
territory i could destroy all their
defenses and then help them defend it
and they don't really care they're just
like oh cool thank you like they don't
have they have no idea alright screw
them over so or this is a ps4 Pro this
is a ps4 Pro this game looks gorgeous
we'll get into some of that today
yeah let's try alright
I mean do it if anyone's any questions
about the game feel free to ask yeah he
may or may not be able to answer them
yeah some people talk about the music on
the main menu that is the Assassin's
Creed scene Ezio steam from - right they
put it in this one which is a alright
alright combat
Oh
these balance can be tricky because you
have way more people on you so it can be
really easy to get overwhelmed so I need
actually shouldn't be avoiding these
guys so your meter is constantly ticking
down up there and you need to still beat
them okay and the best way to do that is
to take out these captains for ya lower
that morale right exactly you see you're
one of your strongest guys go down and
you're like well [ __ ] oh wow so that's
like without a perfect dodge yes
essentially nice so you get a perfect
dodge you activate basically which time
from bayonetta mm-hmm where you can you
get like a chance to everything slows
down you get a chance to do some cool
stuff this ability here I forgot the
name of it but it is really like go-to
from the gameplay I saw yes it's really
good
I like the perfect dodge though just to
kind of reward the player for say new
cool stuff during perfect dodge if I can
hit the right button
that looks doing the right thing he's
going straight for the captain's it
doesn't matter you guys are peasants
peons in the Great War
Oh what is this is um like arrow ability
I can do so good movies used your
perfect dodge to get that like slow-mo
and then use it to activate that attack
that's cool it's really useful doing it
these battles where there's a lot yeah
like some nice AoE this is good move as
well you can rip their shield off oh I
like it
Oh all right okay I was like interesting
so we can talk about this we can't we
can show this mechanic morph later but
they're going mercenaries in this game
that will hunt you down and you have
bounties and if you have a mercenary on
your tail they will sometimes show up
during these battles he's just like I'm
gonna come beat that sweet bounty
so how many weapon types are there so
you got a sword and you got sword you
have your daggers the staff what weapons
like a Mason axe okay so like a pretty
wide variety here and never guessing
righty
there's no shields at this time they got
rid of those that's great I like the
shield a good defense is a very strong
offense in my opinion also just because
with with the perfect dodge mechanic it
just you know yeah more so pitch shot oh
wow
numbers big numbers and you're kind of
like typical actually not doing well
forever really
oh I see I see I see okay I'm doing okay
but yeah I need to killing these guys in
terms of the war okay so the mercy oh
wow and you get a bunch of loot okay yep
yeah killing mercenaries is a great way
in this game to get and it was cool that
it's still like I'm guessing the warring
faction hired them so to speak so it
wasn't like a waste of time to kill yes
Amerson it it still reduces
this guy with this nice so I noticed
basically I don't know what would you
call your I wouldn't call it man and
necessarily because it's that yellow
bars obviously taking up oh yeah you
know for your moves that special move
you did is there like one that like
takes up all the meter yes oh wow crazy
Ultimates or something there are a
couple there's this one arrow move that
does like a thousand times damage please
oh nice parry but they'll take up like
three bars and all your moves throw up
the ability tree in a bit but all the
moves we can also pump great ok the
levels and they'll become stronger but
presumably they take up more are the
moves are there any tie to like the
weapon specifically or is it just mainly
they kind of still work with different
weapons so sounds like bow and arrow
obviously for example there so there are
boa tacks there are like melee attacks
and then there's like your assassin
damage okay so for example that one move
I do my likes my mover I sweep them that
actually does damage based on my
assassin points so if I like put a lot
of points into upgrading the amount of
damage my blade does that actually that
goes into that specific ability
sweep the leg Johnny that's one thing
I'm not using that much there isn't pure
alright first it's a close tug-of-war
here so would you say like if you could
hypothetically farm the lower tier guys
would that kind of like be good enough
or do you mainly want to go for the
leaders you you want to go for the
leaders okay hey you got no meter back
oh nice limited resources as the fgc
would say oh is it time to sweep the leg
I lost that one that one takes the
longest to richer okay broken it looks
really good alright barely did it but we
did it there we go you did it yeah yeah
run run away and Residences oh can you
still get him oh in the leg what's up
John Doe
sorry I haven't meereen chat I got to do
better right okay I got a bunch of stuff
is this a for honor knockoff I wouldn't
say that but I wouldn't be shocked like
some of those mechanics like remind me
of for sure it's not quite as in-depth
as for yeah but I wouldn't be surprised
of the ages it's purple how many of
Aries in our areas I can't read all
right I'm gonna go with the ages you
actually show some of that off so you
got all this jazz we see here here's all
my different what are you using the gray
item it's cuz it was
I like the saddle is using the staff
right now you switched to we did show
off some of these different weapons for
fun a scythe ok scythe will do uh I'll
do like a dagger no mercy why are you a
mod because he actually works here
that's our Ryan Schubert also I have my
helmet toggled well I'm sorry that you
feel that way phase you find all these
cool helmets here thanks for stopping by
I appreciate it
hope you hope you stay
so I'm a pretty big fan of all the the
gear like they look really really rad
and there's some good variety
you got like these crazy like how much
like faces on I like it
they have like your assassin type hoods
as well it's nice little crown is it
would you say it's more aesthetic or
would you say like the assassins like
helmet in this case versus like
something that's heavier actually has
like yeah more distinctive stats so it's
like an assassin hood is gonna have like
assassin base damage okay well you know
like like a helmet of Ares is gonna be
primarily focused more on just like
damage dealing that's actually a really
cool helmet I'm gonna stick with that
for a bit and you can always talk with
the helmet if you uh do my destiny yep
I always have to hide my face cuz of
what Rob did to me same with all this
stuff there's all this crazy girl I need
to actually like dismantle this you want
just mantle here yeah cuz it gets you
apart all these crafting parts which are
used for a lot of things can you make
like ethics and Legendary's okay pretty
regularly however every weapon you can
upgrade to your current level oh so if
you find a piece of gear that you liked
either at stats or its look from like
the very early beginning of the game and
you're like oh I have this epic piece
that's something like level 10 down 50
you can upgrade all that and that's it I
like that I like that too
and I guess it adjust stats and
everything it does it does I haven't
found it yet but I found this one part
called the pilgrim spell but it kind of
reminds me of like really like assassin
yeah and I'm I want to find the rest of
that because that looks are those sets
potentially like tied to certain areas
or they kind of like spread around so it
depends some of them are tied to quests
some of them seem to be tied to areas I
think I just found this one in like a
area I don't think this was tied to
anything specifically cold burns is
asking why is everybody i watch playing
as Cassandra is Alexios bad or something
um I just found Cassandra more
interesting she's kind of got like a
sassier tone to her I like see how this
is a little more straight-laced yeah
also in the office we kind of like split
people up just so that we have both
paths essentially so
I think almost everyone picked up
cassandra though except for like Lucy I
think Lucy like SEOs Bob Jones says Tay
and John Luke never I don't think I've
ever seen that combo we've but Brandon
likes you and Ben better if you do which
is totally fine Brandon come back
Fridays I'm sure you already come
Fridays but that's when John Luke and
then do community Fridays where you guys
get to play games with them I think
they're gonna try to do Soulcalibur Veda
I think it's Friday I believe that's
tentatively the plan yep
so yeah we're on a ps4 Pro Robert a lot
of here let's there's a quest we can go
do all right let's do some side quests
on this gamer really good so you got
your there's a lot in this game maybe
too much a real quick question
no it's from Oh drill captain he wanted
to know the tiers of gear tiers of gear
oh sure
well so you got to got your like
legendary your epics your rares and then
your standards
I've noticed that legendaries you can't
dismantle so I think they do that
intentionally so that you don't
accidentally yeah get rid of a piece of
gear I wish they took from destiny like
you could lock it lock it I wish they
could do that maybe they could like add
that in or something but that would be
nice because I there are some gear
that's pretty cool that like I really
totally want to get rid of but I would
so there are the the side quests that
you see with like that diamonds
oh hello it's gonna board you those are
kind of the more like bigger side quests
that I would say are really well done
pretty interesting or funny you also
have these bounty boards that have sort
of the more like repeatable fetch quest
style stuff so if you're the kind of
person who just wants to constantly be
doing stuff you could go to those bounty
boards but if you're someone who's like
doesn't want to get overwhelmed with
like repeatable quest I would just avoid
those bounty
is my recommendation baby D
unfortunately asking about story and we
can't talk about it so no I can say that
is good I could say that I really liked
it so far I think it's really well
written that's my personal okay
but as far as story specifics we're not
allowed to show or talk about are we
allowed to talk about when the review
actually is going up I don't know
because I know when it is but I just
don't know if we're allowed to say so I
don't know this is a really dumb fun
side quest all right
anvil one gaming asking is there
present-day storyline I honestly haven't
played in ages
don't think that's something we can't
Oracle's and prophecies do more harm
than good you should listen to your gut
I wanted to read his name estupido
that's what I did too there any big
glitches or problems so far I did have
one glitch with a sidequest character
that kind of sucked a change though is
that this game has like multiple save
slots and like auto saves and quick save
as' so I was able to actually reload and
without losing too much yeah it was only
like a minute or two and I was able to
fix it and it didn't happen again
cool but I have had I've had a couple of
bugs but nothing nothing too bad of
course
my parents will gladly pay you for your
troubles so you're a mercenary in this
game which is great because you can just
be like yeah man just pay me and
everyone's okay all right so this guy
because of the Oracle told him that his
mother is gonna die and that his dad's
gonna scream horribly or something that
he's afraid he's gonna hurt his family
and he wants us to go recover his sword
and shield and give them to his parents
so that they can defend themselves from
him because he thinks he's gonna hurt
them okay so he's not a break in awkward
but I talked to this blacksmith I just
didn't want to interrupt this guy after
I scrolled up just so it does have you
like the heart rate there yeah flirty
there's a lot of flirting
I was really excited when I found the
save I was like oh perfect this is great
report all right that's smart
all right questions uh in scab ended
scab he says does it have a Nemesis
system like shadow or kind of like we
can show that here so you go to your
mercenary list here and you do
straight-up have this like list of
here's all the different mercenaries
they'll hunt you down and they have like
a backstory
they have like weaknesses and loot the
only thing is that it doesn't have like
the story like them talking to you type
of station just kind of show up yeah
they kind of show up so it's it's like
close but not quite as memorable as like
the shadow hole with a nemesis system
light yeah it's got like the mechanical
aspects to it but I don't think it's got
the story stuff there but it does have
this and I mean these games are just
endless endlessly spawning dudes
how did Colt burns asking how did the
abilities impact the combat in
comparison to origins pretty
significantly I feel like you have a lot
more ability so you have these like this
wheel are diamond here of like four
different abilities to get four arrow
abilities and then you get 4 melee
abilities and there's only eliminated
you can only have four at a time so you
kinda have to choose which ones you want
and kind of swap them in and out
are sidequest different in any way or
are they mostly just killing they can be
a little different so for example this
one I'm picking flowers this is actually
good way to show off this other thing
the exploration mode in this game when
you pick the game you can pick guided or
you can pick exploration guided this
sort of traditional assassin's creed
they'll just be a waypoint telling me to
go exploration they kind of want you to
figure it out yourself so I get these
clues on the top left here that say
where the flowers are located so if I
hold the map it says all right there in
the center of the forest there in the
force in the center of Red Lake Bay this
is really Bay here so okay it's right
here they're not that complicated
it's not like you're gonna be sitting
there like really trying that once it's
okay not such a like hand-holding
exactly it's a really nice touch and I
like the way they do it yes this is a
pro the truth mm-hmm but we are not
playing 4k because we're obviously not
streaming in 4k right can you have
relations with random people ye not just
any random people mainly in side quests
really didn't stop you like maybe this
blacksmith Mike exactly my kid like it
with this blacksmith here
hello bears animals in this game when we
mess you up yeah that was the the sweet
moves you can't sweep a bear
no dad oh he's got buddies so many
buddies oh I like that one little
charger yeah it's uh if use it on
regular enemy as well kind of knock them
back which is nice
ooh nice dodge just sport and kick him
off Oh someone did say they wanted to
Spartan kick someone real bad yes there
is nothing more satisfying this game
than your stealthy through like a
fortress and you see a dude hanging out
and you're like a wall or like on top of
a wall and you just Spartan kick him off
it's really fun I don't feel good
there's some 3-hundred stuff like
opening the game I think that's already
up on youtube like IGN put it up mhm
you there's a good intro sequence replay
is Leonidas with 300 and that kind of
relates to the story
big boss battles with the god I don't
even think even if that was the thing I
don't even we can't talk about that
no I dunno they've already said this but
like Medusa's in the game that's true
that was a trailer I believe mm-hmm is
there snow and weather in the game there
there is weather like rain and stuff I
haven't seen snow there are snowy
mountains but I haven't been I mean I
would imagine so like these mountains
here I can't really go to them but there
are mountains up here so I imagine there
might be snow maybe up in this area but
I can't say first yeah
commander jefra wants to know is is the
romance like a random fling or a
long-term relation
relationship like thing in Mass Effect
it's a random it's a random flying it
doesn't quite have the mass effect level
so what you'll do is you'll like
sometimes you'll have a fling with
somebody and they're like ah what do I
do now and you're like you should come
hang out on my ship and then they
basically just show up on your ship and
that's it
you can't really talk to them or have
any sort of like deeper romance so it's
a it's pretty surface level compared to
something like Mass Effect but I like it
it's like a step in the in a direction
of making Assassin's Creed more or PG
ish Giulio Enric says uh origins did
wonders for the franchise excited for
this people ask for changes they did it
and now they're complaining as in the
people above him chatting and
complaining about sure I disappointed
some mike has been saying a lot is that
I think if you were already disappointed
with origins and maybe the direction it
was taking the series this isn't gonna
help if anything it's kind of going but
I like a lot of the changes they're
making yeah I mean I liked the combat
changes they made in origins yeah I'm
like seeing them kind of like further
evolve that a bit here is exactly you
mean this to me feels like my favorite
is a scree game is Black Flag okay and I
love the sailing stuff at Black Flag but
then the island town stuff was very old
Assassin's creative sort of separated
like oh you're loading into like a town
right you're loading it to like a small
island this takes that like seamless
open world of origins and then combines
it with like the sailing Island stuff of
Black Flag so it feels like this like
this is like the natural evolution of
what like a modern-day like Black Flag
mixed with origins I read them and we
can and we can actually show that off
today to a little weekend quest we can
take to the Seas yeah we can we can show
off some of that stuff right there all
right yeah so basically she handed him
old-school viagra yes old times there's
a really funny side quest
specifically related to that so what
have you didn't pick that version and
you picked the other option would you
still get the spear I don't think you
get it I think you have to do it for
this okay other side quests make it like
it's an optional thing made that joke I
think this one you have to do okay
uh-huh Chris stürmer says the last AC
game I played was Black Flag I enjoyed
it so how good is this one compared to
that you like Black Flag and you will
like this one there you go I actually
Black Flag was probably the last
Assassin's Creed I really loved really
James we kind of did a bigger scale
battle earlier the conquest stuff you
want to scrub back to the beginning you
can check that out or you can hang it
hang with us and then and then do that
after sub team a bigger than the other
games it's apparently to 2.5 times the
size of origins but it's bigger than
origins and fortunes is huge ok so this
woman who stole it and I already did
[Music]
what a young couple brought you to us
they knew we'd give you a better home
that sword and shield is your
inheritance from them
wait so the thief and the black okay
yeah uh and but one game says if you
didn't like Black Flag we still like
this one I don't know so that was the
quest we made the prophecy come true we
killed his mom and it is that it is bad
all right you got a blindfold from it
yeah sweet blind
all right do you want to do next now
that we're just gonna get on the ship
ruin like that guy just mess up his
whole his whole life was already a sham
and now even more so he finds out that
not only is his mom now dead
but his dad is uh an adulterer I guess
in a way that really if you killed her
first and I guess it's not really his
fault that's a good question was like
that was a good call yeah it's a good
example of here's some of the the fun
like tongue-in-cheek dialogue the game
has this will be a good game to hold
everyone off into Red Dead Redemption to
you says the truth yeah I mean I agree
any games that you can get in before
that time is obviously gonna be a good
time you know like if you haven't got
through spider-man spider-man is
probably you know worth getting through
of course Eric and John Luke ruining
people's lives live on GameSpot that's
kind of true Bob there I like this game
a lot and I'm I'm happy it's coming out
before Red Dead cuz I feel like if it
came out after I dead yeah be no one no
one would talk about triple six saying
you just gave someone PTSD Congrats
alright so we can let's go find some
ships yeah I'm a member when titanfall
two got kind of buried by like cod
battlefield like it was this all in that
same window and just like tiny LT was
actually like it was rough what well it
was definitely better than titanfall for
sure because they had campaign and all
that stuff
that's weird last time I was playing
this there were like a bunch of ships
around here Lords lank 14 it's not such
a big fan of Odyssey so far I think poor
fighting system is rubbish to him or her
the best Assassin's Creed was syndicate
and it went downhill from there okay he
also bought our origins and was easily
acting I like the like the acting so far
I think Cassandra this voice actor is
fantastic I like the story stuff a lot
animation system I mean I like it it
still doesn't feel quite as smooth is
like a from software game kind of style
like there's a little that's kind of
called about origins and I think this is
a little better but maybe not quite as
smooth as I want it but I like it quite
a bit this is the Kraken in this game I
think people are mentioning earlier like
I know you said you like Cassandra more
just for Cassandra mm because of her
like sassy attitude yeah
other people were just saying let like
Alexios is a little bit possibly a
little bit more dry or something
have you experienced his gameplay at all
no I can't really speak to it see my
worries we're gonna blow up ships
instead
fighting three ships at one time a
ramming speed yeah I one of them I want
to break one in half that's a cool thing
you can do do you actually like regen
boat help here you do oh I'm not sure
getting real mess oh I uh I might have I
might have stepped into a fight I can't
wait that's not true
now with that adds to you John Luke you
just got a spread on apart because
there's speedier boats
oh yeah oh he's gonna ram me oh geez
okay okay
and that stop
yes get him get him tell them here
quotas tankier oh he's gonna try to ram
you what happen ooh nice
all right yes what oh I hit a rock okay
I was like you didn't win the fight yet
I know you know son gosh I need a fourth
I need a board that dude yep
bored bored bored bored bored yes okay
is that does that like pause color yeah
it kind of possibly sort of like flag
kind of work the same way that's
hilarious
hide like a reprieve hold on while I sew
assault boats gonna kick them right up
oh the captain's down yep and he'll just
sort of die he'll drown
you're missing the rebored attack defend
when they arrow you then you can arrow
yeah I wasn't doing no I'm just reading
the chat thanks for the tips thanks for
the tips I'd appreciate it someone's got
poison huh yep this poison damage fire
damage all that kind of sweet ship
health restored that's why I wanted to
do it you can plunder them alright
hashtag worth alright while the other
boats watch you they just wait patiently
alright alright well fight now oh he's
so toast
oh he was toast dad okay yeah all right
look for to get on the boredom boredom
boredom come on Oh
stay away this looks like AC Black Flag
yeah it's got a lot in common with it oh
yeah nothing like a crit head shot good
night here's the captain oh did you
switch to daggers yep Oh see up
you'll have the other boats just watch
just well yeah man they're intimidated
they're intimidated also they have honor
they see uh when you when you're
initiating you know docking of the boats
you can only melee there's no ranged
combat until you get back in the boat
then you can engage in ramming speed and
close-quarter Aero combat here if you
got some good spot that other go there
and then I matter that we're not gonna
board him cuz I want to try and we're
going to turn around
uh-oh you're gonna finish him
Sparta right let's do it's good knowing
you
seventeen is that I've done better okay
actually okay a little split properly
still feels good though still feels good
does feel good you can turn off damage
numbers oh yeah yeah we could show uh if
you're curious about that kind of stuff
Kurt well pals thinks that AC Black Flag
has better combat than this ship combat
or I question I don't ship come back on
takes a while to build up so I imagine
I'm gonna get more later okay gotcha
um yeah I I can't really say yeah you
could turn off all this stuff right here
like HUD stuff if you want so for those
curious all of this is optional yeah you
auto heal though right like Auto region
well it's someone said your manual the
old but yeah so you Auto regen once you
finish combat you don't regen in combat
you get an ability that'll let you get
like 30% health back that you can use
but yeah otherwise like income that you
kind of have to be careful but uh either
Fabian or Fabien says AC flat Beck has
black flag has cannons there are no
cannons back then it's true just got out
like 10 DS with arrows
triple six says black flags ship combat
was slower there were definitely moments
where it took matter remember that that
came had like the legendary ships those
are pretty cool I don't know if the game
has anything like that missile loot when
you rend the boat that's true I did but
it doesn't matter they'll tell stories
of how we don't care about loot and will
destroy your boat for fun for fun and
that in itself as a story to tell the
rest of the world
her there she sees shanties their art oh
they sing them in uh in Greek
give them the business yeah and the
javelins
Oh what happened to destroying their
boat no I was over stickum closer than I
am all right unlike the captains of
these boats you know how to swim
exactly Oh see ya get that guy off oh
he's trying to 300 you yep
oh they have two captains not anymore
yeah Oh three look at this little
headpiece man that's fancy
how far is this into the game about 15
18 hours I wanted to get real far to
kind of show off a lot of the different
systems yeah this is a good point where
it's not really nothing spoiler have you
a burner can you upgrade these ships yes
you can
no shields for you this guy's a little
weightier harder than oh did she just
Leonidas kick that MF off the ship hell
yeah she did she just didn't yell this
is sparta all right
I love how this guy plays this triple
six
give me a reason to buy it and not to
buy it it's kind of weird what
so ship here if we go to the ship
yeah you can upgrade this ship here you
get your lieutenants which are people
you can pick up this game's got this
weird system where you can technically
knock anybody out and I'm like Metal
Gear Solid 5 feel like you work for me
now which is Kyle it's got weird fault
in them back to the base sort of
it makes leg no sense like you go up to
like a Spartan right who they're like
they live by like honor and like glory
you just like knocked around you're like
you work for me now they're like ok I
guess it's kind of weird but yeah I
suppose I will do that you'll also do
side quests I catch you characters like
these two characters I did a side quest
for so I got them and and you get more
slots as you upgrade your hull you can
upgrade like rowing stamina crew armor
javelins all this good stuff Calicut
weapon our ship cosmetics I have this
one which i think is because of the like
collector's edition or whatever I got so
I can kind of change the look and you
can also change the way the crew looks
as well which is kind of cool I can add
a little Eagle I'm a ship I can't really
tell you if it's worth the money yet you
guys gotta wait for the review we're
just showing you guys the game yeah
crime wants to know can you do a double
or triple finisher double or triple
finisher what exactly do you mean by
maybe like finish someone and then kill
someone else right after cuz someone
else was also mentioned this game needs
more gore it's got some pretty gory
stuff in the cutscenes
oh no but it's not it's not like the
glorious game ever there is a chain
attack you can do there's like a stealth
style remember in a shadow of war
there's like that Ghost like yeah you
kind of get a version of that except
it's even weirder because you're just
sort of breaking the laws of physics we
like throw it and all the sudden you
just like run up to the dude and like
pull it out alright we can show that off
that's unless I'm like Naruto fourth
Hokage stuff but not as not as exactly
the same I'll see where we are this
island is pretty good we could we could
have over here
do the colored backgrounds of the
lieutenant's or the ship ability
abilities dictate any sort of strength
or rarity yeah a rarity rarity yeah and
as John we had kind of talked about
earlier it kind of starts off a gray
goes to blue goes to purple goes the
legendary right or yeah super gold here
they're singing
appearances by finishers I mean when you
have two enemies with low health can you
cut them both with one move not so far
there may be an ability now let's see do
that later I don't I don't know we about
that's like that they just kind of go
talk amongst themselves got clicks
little clicks yeah yeah no hanging out
those this a new island mm-hmm this is a
Miss Island right here and in the middle
there's some pretty good side stuff here
which also just kind of run around and
do whatever these so she yep uh la lu
zhi says is there a fast travel there is
so that's what the little whatever you
call them the view points the like eagle
points are i think that's how they
worked in origins as well as they're
fast travel games wants some blood
spilled AKA he wants to see some combat
all right let's do some let's do some
combat all right this guy here has a
mission she's knocking to him
hey hey out the way can you speed up day
and night like origins yep you can do
that i didn't actually know that for the
longest time so I was like man I wish
this game had that and Mike was like we
totally do that
what slick gesture says Sasson scree
field you can tell me that doesn't sound
good
I've been wanting that I mean there's a
couple there are a couple that similar
necessarily but they're not oh and
there's also gusta Tsushima yep we're
getting the warlords is it yeah we're
getting a lot of you'll get that fixed
yeah if you're interested in that feudal
Japan fix you are you're getting it I
agree assassin's creed
Erewhon would be great yeah somebody
wants to know are the cultists at the
top of the menu so I can't go too much
into them for story reasons and I can't
show the menu for potential story
spoilers all I could say is that they
are sort of the primary antagonists of
the game similar to how in origins there
was like the snake the order the snake
yeah and you had that like menu of like
your kill list it has a menu similar to
that although it's a little bit more
in-depth in this one but I won't go too
much into that for story reasons and
graphics look good are they better
similar to origins they're very good
this game is gorgeous it also has a
photo mode that I love using you can get
this game just looks great actually the
best way to do it is Kali gross then
like a nice view here I think this game
this game looks really really good it's
got a couple weird like you use zoom in
a little bit and obviously that's like a
lower texture that's like rendering but
it's really good I'd love to see it on
PCs it's like as if if you took a
screenshot and then zoomed in it yeah
I've been using the photo mode a lot and
this is maybe one of my favorite like
looking Assassin's Creed games I love
the environments in this game say what
you want about UV but they do make some
eye candy they do I'm just looking
they definitely do okay
Jay Collins asked me a question it's not
crazy it's obviously an evolution on
origins or is it just origins with a
different skin it's more of an evolution
I'd say it kind of has a lot of stuff to
it
a lot of improvements the level of
improvements I don't know exactly what
you're looking for but it definitely
isn't just origins with a different skin
it's more than that we're gonna try and
get some my abilities over to somewhere
stealthy yeah
it looks like AC origins married to AC
Black Flag kind of does John Luke do a
lot of photography I don't nothing I
know me yeah I used to in college yeah
but not so much like lately though and I
just I really hope that I was tripping
and I didn't sue how's a bird stopped
midair because he's a badass oh no I
don't have enough points do this
manually oh that's way more gory than
just your normal combat oh right in the
side or something oh I'm gonna assume
she didn't go for the goods but man did
it really look like she did a lot of
times that's not very nice that's like
one of the worst ways to probably go out
there but so you need to burn these
these like no signal see yeah I did I
wasn't tripping it did do man that's
about right
you need to bring these war chests here
fun tip before they burn Emmons loot
them because I actually have a lot of
resources in them nice nice little tip
there yeah you look forward to more tips
like that in our eventual tips video I'm
working on yeah what I got to do is like
there's a little splitter that's down
underneath the table and sometimes like
when the hosts stretch their legs a
little bit it kind of kick it and then
it'll do that no signal flicker for like
the hottest of seconds why are they
facing the wall it's a good question
they were meditating or reading
something
where I can just will there be a story
co-op or something oh that's the move
yep and I can chain it dude you are the
fourth Hokage you are actually the
fourth Hokage it's really funny when you
throw like a on a doing like a tower and
then you just run up there and you're
like huh how did she do that can you do
it more than twice in any way you can
upgrade it it kind of breaks the stuff a
little bit cuz like in theory if there's
five well I don't know what the max
limit is but in theory if there's four
guys or five guys that you had to deal
with you could just chain all four oh
yes
come on whoo nice parry excellent I
don't I don't see the parries enough I
should I mean like both seem pretty
rewarding
I almost I'm curious like do you feel
like the perfect dodge is like like
there's more benefits there I feel like
just that slow down gives you so much
more benefit than the parry but I can't
tell you I've only seen Perry once so
one thing you can do with the Perry
that's cool is if you parried it does
slow down for a sec and then if you
dodge right after you'll dodge out of
the animation and it gives you more time
and slow down just like I'd kinda like
comboing to your defensive abilities
around it's sort of a big tip I would
say is anytime you get like the perfect
dodge or slowdown that's some time to
use like maybe some other abilities
so those aren't you tax in half oh there
we go right under the chin strap
that's such a silly question who to win
Batman versus Oh for some reason in my
head I thought like actual Batman
fighting yeah Harry Hughes Wharton says
his comment similar to blood-borne
because it looks similar I mean in the
sense there's like a dodge and a parry
but you don't have a stamina meter no
you don't stamina meter or anything like
that I guess in the sense that you
expect like Dark Souls had shields and
blood-borne didn't and then origins had
shields and a dozen kind of I can sort
of see how you're making that connection
but it's not if you're expecting like
blood-borne level combat it's not that
Antony's still perplexed as to why those
guys are just saying the law really
important man yes mercury you can equip
a spear there's a bunch of weapons you
can actually I can try a switching
around here do you two have personal
YouTube's ask James I mean I have them
but I haven't not really put anything on
there I think mark may use it now is I
have like a playlist I made on there
where I just yeah just to keep just to
have so it's like hey if you're ever
interested in the stuff I make check out
that playlist
let's count what I use tax collector
Greaves they all increase your ability
to tax people I'm just kidding
alright Wow joy hayabusa says
blood-borne is my favorite game of all
time it's one my favorites up there for
me it's for sure and every time I come
back to it it still feels as good as
like the first time somehow or maybe
even better to some degree you know just
because we've got such a good handle on
it now that it's just like it feels so
clean to be you know good at this game
you can try this this harder area here
see swap around my stuff do it
switch up the weapons let's try this
I was mace all right and then let's do
like a sword a rare family sword was
that the soup Edo one the one that you
had to know it might be Hildy you
thieving wife high relie possible help
with some guys broken spear oh is that a
good boy
best boy oh yeah a lot of dogs in here
seems good best boy there are
mercenaries with dogs and sometimes you
have to kill the dogs J holin says is
the crafting system of the same as
origins as it felt repetitive hunting
animals and collecting resources to
upgrade your gear so it's similar you're
not hunting yeah I mean it's kind of the
same but you got to did you get to
dismantle in origins I don't know okay
well he really helps I've never felt at
least so far where that I've been like
I'm I don't have enough or anything yeah
if you're trying to like constantly keep
maybe a certain weapon upgraded to your
level that might take a lot of resources
to do but if you're just kind of going
with the flow I haven't really run into
any issues uh can you ride a horse
someone's just asking yes a horse you
can summon that any time so we could we
could go explore this island after all
right so I gotta kill that dude okay
slick dresser said you did get to
dismantle an origins okay yeah okay
uh Tony Rex says can you switch up
armors too or will you be looking
Spartan ish most of the time no no you
can totally switch it up so you can look
like an assassin yeah depending on if he
has enough pieces of gear but yeah I
could
I got a nineteen version I don't know
that's better than the one you equipped
so you can kind of goes like like this
sort of have a more Sasson look to your
to yourself which is kind of nice
yeah you like yeah like Spartan outfits
they have like a Fenian outfits kind of
mercenary outfits all sorts of stuff do
myself an eyepatch if I want the dude
Ben would be all about that life oh yeah
alright so I need to kill that guy who
is the leader of this island and also by
luck he is a member of the cult so I get
like there's double reasons to kill him
okay and we can show that yeah we can
show Killian we just can't show like so
I someone say is there a fast way to
maneuver when on land because this map
looks huge at horse yeah horse is the
fastest way to go okay that's a lot of
dudes there I'm guessing if you change
agar he doesn't die and like no
let's try and take out some of these
dudes first yeah you got a thin the herd
exactly can I do it from here no
Cristina Dublin saying what other
equipment do you have that will help you
against enemies we as a bone arrows with
skills as well as the weapons he decides
- nice
yeah you got a bone arrow we got your
weapons get your spear which is sort of
my like assasin blade and now you can
upgrade as well of course all your
different abilities that you can decide
to use mm-hmm the abilities are the big
thing it's like for example I have an
agility where if you hold down the
assassin button you'll do like a
critical assassin you'll do more damage
which is good for trying to take out
some higher-level enemies that you
normally wouldn't be able to assassinate
as well and there's so much a boot here
it's a lot of loot in this game I can't
read your name on YouTube unfortunately
because looks like characters but it
says I spent 200 hours in origins it
looks like I'm gonna spend a thousand in
Odyssey skins huge as you mentioned like
roughly two and a half X you know well
that's probably water but it's still
pretty big whoa oh yeah see there
they're on to you they're moving though
that's better I want that there's no way
I could take him out on that little tiny
is there actual preparation for the
assassination or is it just usual kill
him boring I mean he's kind of prepping
by killing all the other people alright
I guess unless you're talking about
something more involved yeah it's not
like Whichard style where I feel like I
have to find a book and research
okay so Sandrine Sharon says what makes
obviously stand out among the rest of
the AC series that's right how much am I
gonna do
Oh ed I got us dead so unfortunate have
to confirm his kill
she means I've sustained over there so
wait so so we just gotta take out some
grunts yeah he's got him you would think
their Posse would be afraid now that the
big leaders gone but that's not the case
oh wow a power strike or something
Oh like God just he did a Slamma jamma
as i like to call it Oh watch out hello
there guys a lion pelt no problem those
lines in this game thank you kind of
gave you some iframes anyway oh here we
go perfect dodge No
oh they got she they called in for their
backup yep boundaries just love to show
up one here in the middle of a fight
like this as they did in a shadow war
except they come in and tell you oh I
range on exactly I'm here again time to
die okay sorry about that guys it's
pretty bad I loved it Oh God level 20 oh
well you're like 19th confirm this kill
yeah it's ease doable it'll be a little
tough but oh dude you got a lion friend
too okay boo Spartan wore armor though
yeah check that oh we're good right
oh we're just you know they'll never
know
oh yeah yeah that's how it's good it's
get a matching helmet for it yeah pretty
close yeah pretty close got to play that
fashions Creed fashion crease fashion
Creed how many different endings who
knows how many different endings I know
but I don't know keep it very ambiguous
you gotta play the game all I could say
is that because of the way the game has
choices that there are actual multiple
endings okay
I can I can say for a fact that there
are multiple endings okay but I don't
want to admit yeah you don't specify
there could be like 10 there could be
like 5 there could be a hundred I'm you
know obviously these fake numbers yeah
lest the wrath of ubiquitous software it
comes after us I think I think they
don't get these dreams anymore because
real trouble with Peter
Oh Peter I've broken Bargo so one thing
I've always liked may try to make sure
that I didn't do but I am so paranoid
about it even though like I've been here
forever no I understand I mean this one
I'm just like don't don't accidentally
go to the what is that another person
yeah that happens sometimes dual will
just show up yep there there oh that's
the same prison okay right here I vote
max bounty at my five star GTA yeah GTA
like means I have five mercenaries
currently hunting me right no problem
take them all down Jesus don't regret
the day it was bad I can't do this okay
so what's the plan then
well there's multiple ways I could
either escape yeah okay let's escape
I'll probably the best plan just get
away from them the mercenaries will
still hunt you but at least those other
dudes will kind of leave me alone then
and out the herd Oh aggressive rooster
chicken dang that thing actually does
some damage
yeah they're all like trying to attack
me
what is going on why are they why are
they trying to attack me maybe the
mercenary is some type of animal master
oh you got an arrow shot at you I think
oh my god yeah they're just following me
come on how did that not kill I know
all right now is that all right I could
deal with these dudes
yes a little bit Oh
faceplant dang I really so over again
yeah yeah Oh
depending on where it auto-saves alright
let's find out see let's find out it's
okay I mean this is an earlier state for
me we're just kind of showing it off
yeah
specialized trained battle chickens yes
correct
you know a game is good when you get to
kill a chicken mm-hmm there's a pretty
good menu tip here that was something to
the effect of like like the best way to
win combat is to get the enemy health to
zero and your health above zero
basically them saying get good without
saying good good well there was a game
that says it literally says that maybe
it's dead cells yeah that was just like
plastered on the walls oh he's get live
kid I'd have to redo all that do it is
there another way to approach it
mmm all right then you do you what's
next on the Cassandra agenda go try and
kill maybe that was lower yeah what's
the let's go explore all right oh cool
you're gonna show off the horse-riding
as well someone didn't ask to see yep
that's a sweet horse yep this is the
skin you get further I think the
collector's edition Oh need some carrots
it real fast there
there are a lot of variation in the
wildlife ask Dillon Duke a lot of bears
a lot of wolves some Lions snakes it's a
decent amount elk stuff like that all
right I might have to hop off forest for
a sec and it's good knowing you
until next time our four legged friend
someone's asking about whether we got
some rain
sweet sweet sweet rain wandering around
like the you know the origins is very
sandy this reminds me a lot more of like
witcher 3 do you find any mythical
creatures or is it historical somewhat
the crimson card at yukio shoutouts to
you making it into jump horse for some
stupid reason but I mean they've shown
that you find Medusa yeah so she's
somewhere yeah and like I don't know if
there's room for Medusa there's
technically room for other ones right
right but who knows like that's the only
one we know for sure sorry we when you
were I don't think you're in the office
I had I had a deep argument of
conversation with Jordan and gadge about
how and why Yugi shouldn't be in jump
for it okay give me your pitch why I
said he shouldn't be because one none of
the creatures he summons actually comes
to like life they're just like
holographic they don't exist even though
that's how they're gonna portray it all
but in like isn't in the show like
they're based on real creatures yes this
was what gadje was saying but that would
that mean that everywhere they fought
would have to be like the shadow verse
and not like Shadow Realm
yeah the shadow realm Oh what if he has
a mover he summons he like sends them to
the Shadow Realm
I'm sure he does but what happens the
whole other time he's actually inking
I'm so sorry
I summon exodia anyways back to us acids
creed anyways it was dumb gadje was off
what what the heck yeah that happens a
couple times
he's like my heart the horse was a shy
and he was like hold on I don't have my
full armor get hit wait ah yes take a
little nap everyone watches night
becomes day now go oh they're right in
the face
oh my way horse Oh Oh is it dead
I have no no wait it's fine no good
there we go
the horses I know I'm out of here oh
yeah you wants nothing to do with oh no
don't run come back there's more bears
over there oh no I heard one or no
they're just no my horse a dumb horse we
warned it we warned your horse we said
if you go over there
there's a good chance that you're gonna
get mauled by bear and it happened don't
even know where my horse went the horse
said fu man ran off he said a big fu is
there a snowy region we don't know maybe
there might there is a area up north
which if there would be a snow region
that would make sense but looking up and
nope no there's another bear where was
asking about wildlife here you go lots
of bears oh wait he's smelling her him
her I don't know what sex your horses oh
no she must have declined
there we go oh my horse please come back
I could probably just thought I should
probably just give them a comeback what
oh my god dilly there's more bears why
not move I meant to use oh he's so angry
go oh come on come on
Wow 10,000 crit headshot somehow even
though it kind of looks like it hit his
back in more berries wow these graphics
are insane says Tony Rex they're really
good
James hopes there's a cracking you know
are you know how hard that fight would
be in your boat I'd love for there to be
a Kraken I haven't really encountered
any like ship pasta granted I feel like
I'm still really early on the the ship
stuff mm-hmm
you spend a lot of time on the on the
land at the beginning well poison
oh he dead
anyone else these people
they're not gonna attack me it isn't
gonna be any spoilers here no Dino see
you gamer we're just doing boiler free
experience we're currently looking for
another coldest Oh
yep these banditos seems like it I know
if he was on my side or not though stuck
and I'm not I think I'm good okay yeah
these these Spartans don't care about me
does he ever yell this is sparta
no she doesn't yell it either no they've
probably yelling this is RSA I'll see
myself out now okay so somewhere they
might be in a cave nearby oh that's good
air so this one like the physics
freakiness of this wait I feel let it
recharge dang or you don't have enough
time enough for it I just yeah if you
want to check out ship gameplay we do
that earlier so
you can scrub back though for sure or
they bounced down below and the candor
in this cave here
sweet still get them is the park or
similar to origins mm-hmm
up there there there by themselves yeah
I wasn't expecting that
oh there's a wolf okay that's a good boy
not anymore actually no wait never mind
I can't use it how does he not sent you
I'm using me so much not used to this
animation but it does some damage Oh
and as the like the site you kind of a
charged up attack which is cool
oh it's a yeah that's good it'll like
knock them back in oh he's got armor
moves I guess it's also good way to uh
it goes through shields as well
it's that overhead I'm used to I'll
switch back is I want to see the enemy
odd what is your favorite weapon ask
Dylan be actually like the spear a lot
the boss how you doing poor dog oh yeah
poor dog oh he's just a good boy
actually he wasn't that good because he
didn't sense us coming his senses were
adult he's old
our ships customizable yes to some
degree to some oh yeah you can there's
skins for them and then there's also you
know your lieutenants and
like Prime members buy more skins
there's also a there is a micro
transaction store the same way origins
had although right now it's not online
so I can't actually even look at it
didn't you do a video on that last year
that was far cry get this oh he's got a
little hop kick oh so good yeah oh good
all rights confirm that what do I get
from him Wow a waistband
cool awesome kill them
let's go kill the rest of these people
any other questions or things yeah time
to ask because we've got only about 10
to 15 minutes left of what we're allowed
to stream we only allowed to stream for
about anyone wants to see anything else
someone wants me to I can I go fast
travel to some of the other places I've
already visited yeah and the save people
are curious otherwise it will just be
murdering the rest of these people at
the abandoned mine they're a buffer on
ship skins I don't know he said or are
they pointless Oh like do the skins buff
the ship oh there there's a separate
stuff for upgrades available as well I
mean not that you have it you know I'm
just curious because he has like double
double when he handed me no I didn't see
anything like that he's on fire yeah yes
oh here we go oh he's got a purple on
him oh right yes still good it's so good
that's a bad the best is when they're on
a cliff it's so satisfying
okay like that
who's hype for this game says Marcin
Dylan says I'm beyond hyped yeah if you
like to decisons good origins if you
like Black Flag I think you'll be pretty
even in this game this game is really
cool
James S says murder the innocent for
science because this game lets you it
does the game so yeah like other
Assassin's Creed games if you were like
killing us as people it would like
desync you because it's like oh that's
not you can't simulation this one
it totally lets you do it it just counts
as a murder and it increases your bounty
nice so a little more get that wanted
yeah increase that wanted level he can't
go too much into the specifics of the
cultists no so for those asking like but
they are like he said earlier they're
kind of like the family members and
whatnot that you did go after in origins
yeah it's a similar idea where there's
like a group of people you need a kill
although there the menu is like like a
little more in depth I feel like then uh
it was in origins which is cool is there
a difficulty selection in this game like
origins yep there's a difficulty
selections beginning of the game and I
believe you can change it anytime you
want as well if we tell the date when
the review comes out then Ubisoft will
have to kill them they'll have to
assassinate us if anything
yeah we're now and we're not sure if
we're allowed to tell you when the
reviews coming up but stay tuned look
forward to it
that's always that's always weird
because sometimes it's okay yeah
sometimes sometimes it's okay I just
play on the safe side yeah I don't know
for sure
another thing I like compared to origins
is I feel like there aren't quite as
many of these like question mark icons
which were sort of like oh it's like a
base or it's littered with them right
yeah I feel like they toned it down just
a little bit
is there a warning sound when
mercenaries are near you yes yes he
makes this like kind of like siren sound
battleborn or something that they're
approaching all right what's your next
thing that you're gonna show off here in
the last let's get into the top of this
mountain here good a Vista get a nice
view is there anything in the world
doing all out of show yeah can't really
show any story based which is okay
because I'd rather avoid that anyway I
don't want to spoil that for people and
then yeah there's like some later
sidequest you stuff we can't really show
any choices or anything like that and
you like major like oh these are the big
choices that'll have ramifications can't
show any of that stuff
alright the character is interesting now
could this be the next Ezio I like
Cassandra a lot so far I really like her
voice actor I like her character is the
difficulty about the same as origins
yeah I'd say so what do you think about
Assassin's Creed going full RPG I don't
mind it I like you quite a bit
now things are getting better like this
one has a lot better side quest then
origins did in my opinion some of they
are good in origins but others were like
really boring this does a lot better job
having more interesting side quests
quiet note arts quiet Knight wants to
know can you increase the cooldown speed
on skills question so you can upgrade
abilities and it's I don't know if that
in mmm doesn't seem like that decreases
cooldown speed ability that and there's
like equipment does that either so your
inventory you get so you'll have like
yeah and then they'll have like a slot
and you have these engravings here that
you can like apply so I see a lot of
damage modifiers of damage crit damage
to animals yeah so it seems like a lot
of damage damage based up there are
stone that's stuff that's like hey if
you use the spartan kick ability maybe
put this on your piece of armor so it'll
do 20% work damage there are ones that
like get back your ability points faster
but as far as the cooldown on specific
ability they're 25 down for all
abilities there you go that totally
isn't thing that should be awesome
that's what I did in God of War I mainly
I mean the comboing stuff was fun but I
used a lot of I wouldn't heavy runic
so I was just spamming abilities a lot
25% is pretty big that I should actually
once I can unlock that I should do that
is there any part of the open world you
can't show off show us there just
exploration stuff so they actually did
not give me any restrictions as far as I
look this well we don't know if there's
a class know up there but you can see
yeah as far as part of the map there
were no restrictions they just said no
story stuff presumably there's gonna be
some parts of the map that has some
spoilers but it doesn't see
so that's the the furthest area over
there
I could go to I don't know if maybe
maybe it
I can't tell us if it stops right before
the snow or not yeah I don't really know
oh nice little viewpoint
does that become past travel in mmm-hmm
that could fast trouble here any time I
want
is there Sparta yep
Spartans on this game so happens all the
major like Greek cities are represented
here so I was asking about if the open
will the modern day stuffs in the game I
can't talk about the modern day stuff
but I can say that yeah it's it's a it's
a thing all right
well last minute here I lost two raw of
questions before we wrap up yeah is
there anything any wants to see we got
seven minutes we're technically yeah the
show we have we're playing on ps4 Pro
NIC thirteen uh it's good-looking I'd
love to see it on PC like maxed out can
you get magical weapons magical weapons
not that I'm aware of
so far maybe though what's your favorite
city favorite city so far uh well I'm
not I've done the whole game yet but I'm
at Athens and that's pretty cool it's
like really big big area lot to do yeah
you like like if I go like here for
example you kind of get like a more I
haven't Alessandra's played a little bit
on a normal ps4 someone's asking if it
still looks good on a first gen it still
looks good it doesn't look quite as good
the frame rates a little more choppy I
want to say from his experience when he
was showing me X mantra wants to know
how well is this game optimized not bad
the only thing I've noticed that is a
little annoying is the menu sometimes
take a little bit to pop in when you lo
to them like it'll take like two yes
some just like five seconds and early
yes a little bit MacPhail wants to know
YouTube is doing its compression thing
but does this game look better than
origins
yeah yeah I mean I I I can't do like a
full comparison
I thought organs looked amazing hard to
say
I would love to see like a digital
foundry video that did an exact
comparison but I like the the
environments better tone your XS thank
you for the gameplay guys have a great
day thank you you too no problem
can you side with Athens as 99 6x
Brandon it's not a question you can
answer
sorry well is it can you side with
Athens so yeah I mean in in the conquest
stuff you can pick which faction faction
aside with as far as that as far as how
that plays into the overall story I
actually personally don't know yet that
hasn't really come into play but even if
it did I wouldn't say but yes in the
mechanic stuff you can totally side with
them in fact that conquest ballot at the
beginning I was on Athens side okay
James says it'll make a great potato
mode shadow wolf says are there any
references to Greek gods oh yeah there
we were earlier there's like a temple at
the side and I was at they make
references to like I have armor like I
had the short like the gauntlets of Ares
and stuff like that so you get you get
different armor and and based on like
Greek gods and people talk about them
and you see statues of them said oh
that's represent a.m. says can you go
into the mountains next to focus and
malice or Mesa donee a bit to the west
and I'm top that's up top right there's
focus malice and Macedonia no you can't
go here okay that's where the mountain
would be oh you know I know the perfect
place to end it on all right
let's get there let's get there nice and
quick I'll head to of this nice statue
with Zeus
Pantera Vall says how good is the combat
where the other game is it comparable to
I like it it's slowly I guess you
haven't laid origins because I would say
it's like that but I owe
me or the question it's kind of gotta
influences from like from software games
I don't think it's as tight as those
like us I mean I hate always using the
soil now claim I better get it like it's
it's what happens when people want to
compare to something else so I think
it's fair especially given what they are
asking
it's like souls light kind of right you
know way and less forgiving you know but
still rewarding when you get the dot
perfect dodge off or the parry off can
you wear Athens gear yep you can wear
gear of all sorts of factions how much
how many naked statues are there funny
you should ask
of course all right are there any time
these could not be more personally
wouldn't be able to talk about Easter
eggs even if they were in the game just
because obviously they're you know I
haven't found any yet but I you know it
actually Mike said there were a couple
cool ones yeah we can't we can't talk
about yeah oh my gosh who's who you hang
over anything you know it's not gonna
end better than that
so no probably not thank you John Luke
of course for playing thanks everyone
for tuning in we have more stuff coming
for Assassin's Creed Odyssey of course
I'm gonna have a guy obviously we're
gonna our review we've put up some
gameplay so if there's something you
missed in here maybe it's in that I
think we did show off some animal
hunting and gameplay that we didn't do
here today yep so that's their make a
photo says correct there is photo mode
for there's a photo mode how is he
climbing this you know wow alright I
don't all right final show it but I'm
reluctant
there you go take a photo nailed it
alright anyways thanks everyone for
tuning in we're gonna be back tomorrow
as we are Monday to Friday
John Luke will be back Friday with been
doing some soul calibur beta yep and
yeah until next time thank you guys all
so much for tuning in appreciate it any
last words
John Lee no um stay tuned for our
eventual review awesome more coverage
about this game cool peace out